Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We are back, and today we are going to marvel
at the capabilities of NVIDIA’s incredible
image generation AI.
And, we will see together that we can all
become witchers.
Previously, they were able to create an incredible
AI that can take a piece of text from us,
and create an appropriate image.
Or, it could also give us a little more artistic
control as it could even transform a rough
sketch into a beautiful output image.
Variant generation was also possible.
Or, if we didn’t feel like drawing, it could
also take segmentation maps, which specify
which region should be what.
The output was again, a beautiful photorealistic
image.
So these were mostly landscapes.
And what about human faces?
Can we generate human faces too?
And I wonder if we could also edit them?
If so, how?
Well, NVIDIA already has incredible works
for generating human faces.
Look.
This is their StyleGAN 3 AI, and as you see,
my goodness.
These are incredible high quality faces, and
we even have a tiny bit of control over the
images.
Not a great deal, but a little control is
there.
It works on art pieces too, by the way.
And, this new technique finally gives us a
little more creative freedom in editing these
images in 5 different ways.
How?
Well, check this out!
Oh yes, one, we start sketching, and out comes
an image of this quality.
Wow.
This truly is a testament to the power of
AI these days.
It doesn’t just generate images out of thin
air, but here, we can really harness the power
of this AI and the best part is that we don’t
even need to be an expert at drawing.
So cool!
Two, if we don’t feel like drawing, but
we would really like to see some well-known
people as cubist paintings, this can do that
too.
Three, if we have an image with snow, and
we feel like chocolate, vanilla, or cherry
ice cream would be so much better for snowboarding,
also, not a problem.
And here comes my favorite.
Four.
We can make people into Witchers.
I think I might make a good one.
Look.
This is Obi-Wan Károly, a synthetic image
of me made by an AI with an added beard.
And, look.
Hm-hmm!
You don’t want to mess with Witcher Károly,
do you?
Hmm, so who else would make a great witcher?
Well, here are some of my favorites.
For instance, Grimes.
Beardyman, Skrillex, Robin Williams, Obama,
and The Rock.
All excellent witchers!
And, five, it can not only produce these images,
but even interpolate between them.
What does that mean?
This means that not only the final image,
but intermediate images can also be generated.
Look, we are going from a photo, to a sketch,
to a Mona Lisa-style painting.
While we are looking at these wonderful results,
I would like to send a huge thank you to the
authors and they were very patient and took
quite a bit of time off their busy day to
delight you Fellow Scholars with these animations.
As a result, some of these animations you
can only see here on Two Minute Papers.
That is a huge honor.
Thank you so much!
So, how easy it is to use?
So easy that it only takes a minute to produce
such excellent results, and it likely means
that this will be an excellent tool in democratizing
artistic image editing and giving it into
the hands of everyone.
Now make no mistake, this is a research paper,
not a product.
Yet!
But NVIDIA has an excellent record of transferring
these works into real products.
For instance, they published a similar Audio2Face
paper in 2017, and now, just a few years later,
it is out there for everyone to use.
How cool is that?
I really hope that this work will also have
a similar fate!
What a time to be alive!
So, does this get your mind going?
What would you use this for?
Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!